で そういうふうなことで心が
死んじゃったら次の心が生まれる
その法則はずっと変わらないんだと
それは輪廻と言うんですね
この物体が死ぬか死なないか
そんな全然もう無関心で
体という物体 体という物体はゆっくりゆっくり出てきて大きくなるもので
それでその中で心活動して物体捨てられたらそれで壊れていっちゃうし
また他のところでゆっくりゆっくりと新しい体が現れるんであって
で それは我々俗人たちが
世の中の人々がすごい興味ある輪廻転生なんです
生まれ変わりなんですね
どんな体にするかと 仏教はどんな体になるかっていうことは全然まああまり興味ないというか
心の流れが輪廻転生だと
ですから 人間 この俗世間の中でこの輪廻転生を信じますとか
輪廻はもう私はあの人は死んでこういうところで今生まれてるんだというふうに喋ったりするでしょうに
その場合は心の流れじゃなくて新しい体のことを考えているんですね
体のことを抜きにして輪廻を考えちゃうと
なんだもう当たり前ではないかとわかるんです
輪廻しないのは不可思議で不思議であって
輪廻することは当たり前だと
体なしに物事を考えちゃうと
自分の心は今止まったことがありますかね
一度もないでしょう 止まれないでしょうに
心が 止まれ止まれと言ったって
例えば悪いことを考えていると
じゃあやめなさいと言ってやめられないでしょうに
そのエネルギーある限りはずっと妄想しっぱなしで
そこでやめるためにはどうするべきかというと
全く強意に他のことを考えなくちゃいけない
例えば人が泣いていると
それこの怒りの感情が出てきて泣いていると
おい 泣くのはやめなさいと言ったっても
やめなさい やめないでしょうに
それで突然その人を笑わせてあげちゃう
あげちゃうと それで泣くのはやめますけど
新しい対象について心が流れていくんです
止まることできない 輪廻っていうのはそういうことなんです
だからそこでついでにある心
ある体が壊れたりするし
どこかでまた新しい体がゆっくりとじわじわと生まれてくるし
それとは関係なく輪廻は強烈にもうやってるんです
一向の細胞になったんだからって
心の流れが別にどうったことなく強烈に動いてるんです
で 以上で心のそこは終わります
で 式は説明しましたしね
まあ一応分析論はその辺で終わります
それからこの一旦この
アビダンマの基本というのは心と物質の分析なんですね
だからずっとやってきたのは
まず私は物質の分析をして
それから心の分析と心のいろいろ法則という
で これで膨大な量をそれで割っちゃうんですね
それは今まで勉強したのはほとんど学生さんのアビダンマなんですね
で それでアビダンマのプロになったかというと
そうじゃないんです ただ基本は覚えたというぐらいのことなんです
それからこのアビダンマでは
このアビダンマに関係あること
確かにありますけどね
この大人のアビダンマでは
そういう心の分析だけではなくて
この心の成長すると 心がいろんな働きをする
そこら辺は説明しているんですね
これは実践的なアビダンマなんですね
で そこはこのテキストにもこの第七章でしたっけ？ 第七章
七章のサヌッチェーヤ
これどうやって読むんですかね
摂取分別処 これからはこのそんなに難しくない
普通の説法みたいなもので
あの私たちにとっては
この心はこういうふうに生まれるんだ
こういうふうに消えるんだという
この科学的な説明があってもなくても構いません
例えば私はがんになったところでがんではわからなかったんだけど
もう体の調子が悪くて
お医者さんにまあ調べてもらったところでがんですよと
それでお医者さんがそれはどんな種類のがんですかと
この細胞がどのように分裂していくんですかとかね
そういうすごい科学的な医学的な説法をするんだと
ずっと何時間もかけて
がんその自分の体に住み着いているがん細胞
いろいろありますからね
そのがん細胞の種類と
そのがん細胞の DNA の働きと
もうこういうことで こういうところで
こういうこういう DNA のプログラムがあったんだから
こういうふうにがんになりますよと
言うと 今日の授業終わりましたから
明日も来てくださいと
そこで 2時間ぐらい喋ってもらって
またもうがんの専門家として知識量と時間かかりますからね
明日もいろいろサンプルを持って説明しますからと言って
それでそのお医者さんがもう 1年間ぐらいその患者さんに自分がかかっているがんのことを説明したって
何か役に立ちますかね
それで それでは役に立ちませんね
今までやったアビダンマの説明
私は一応役に立つところをずっと言ったんだから時間なくなったんだけどね
純粋にアビダンマのことだけ言っちゃったら
これはもう本当に 2時間 4時間で終わります
説明はね でもそれだけじゃないということで
ずっと時間かかってしまいましたけどね
で この章では摂取分別
摂取分分別章では そこら辺はもうちょっと扱っているんですね
人に役に立つことをね
これはちょっとやめましょうと
で 例えばこういうこういうがんだから
あなたはまあこういうこういうことをした方がいいんですよとかね
まあこういうこういうことを食べた方がいいんですよと
なんとかとか言ってくれると
あの講義よりは役に立つ
でも講義もいくらか必要なの
例えば糖尿病だよと言われたら
ああそうですかと じゃあどうすればいいか
あんたね 砂糖とかね まあそういう
あの 何て言いますか 糖が入っているものは控えなさいと
はい 分かりましたと それでその人はもうそれでうまくいかないんですね
その場合は 糖尿病というのはこういうことだと
それで糖分がどんな食べ物から体に入りますかと
そういう説明をしてもらって
なぜならば その説明なければ
あんたご飯控えなさいと
毎日 2杯食べてたでしょうに
1回 1食も それ 2杯ではなくて
まあ半分にしてくださいと言ったら
その人はこの茶碗半分ご飯食べるかもしれませんだけど
その代わりに食パン 3枚食べる可能性あるでしょうに
ですから 糖尿病の場合は
このこういうことをしなさいというだけでは足らないんですね
ちょうどお医者さんとか栄養士がでパン屋
これぐらい糖分ある ご飯にはこれぐらいある
ジャガイモにはこれぐらいある
もうもうサツマイモにはこれぐらいあるとかね
たとえキャベツを食べたっても
キャベツにもこれぐらい糖が入ってるんだと
それであなたは一日これぐらい以上糖分は取ってはいけないと
じゃあそれで一日はご飯だったら茶碗の半分と
食パンだったら一日枚でいいんだと
それで枚食べちゃっても
ちょっと物が物足らないと思うならば
回に分けて食べなさいと
回に分けて食べて その代わりにこの杯飲み物を飲んだりとかねしなさいとか
そういう風に説明してあげると本人がわかるでしょ
ですから まあこのアビダルマっていうのは大体そんな感じで
ただ修行しましょう 精進しましょうというだけでもうまくいかない
瞑想しましょうと それ悟りますって言ってもうまくいかない
どこかで間違っちゃうんです
糖尿病患者さんと同じく
それできめ細かく分析したっても
またどこかで間違っちゃう
一日自分がどれぐらい糖分取るべきかと
それをどのように取るべきかと教えてくれないと
それまた習慣病習慣病だからね
それうまくいかない ですから
心を育てることも習慣病と同じ
我々煩悩があって輪廻転生するのは習慣病なんですね
ですから ちゃんと分析して知識理解を得て
それからどうするべきかという両方の説明が欲しいんです
いくらかは科学的な知識と
それから実践的なノウハウ
両方必要です それでこちらではこの 第7章で
まずマーティカという項目ですか
このマーティカっていうのは
この アビダルマ思想家の世界では大変有名なんです
いろんな教え いろんな教えにはこの項目作る
この項目できたらもう仕事をほとんど終わったんだと
カテゴライズする お釈迦様はずっと説法をなさった説法にこの項目をつけちゃうんです
大変な学問的な仕事なんです
いろんな項目をつけてつけてつけて
その項目だけ覚えておくと
もう仏教はほとんど知ってることになっちゃうんで
ですから このお坊さんたちの中で
このプロ中のプロっていうのはマーティカダラなんですね
マーティカをもうちゃんと身に着いているんだと
項目全部持ってるんだと
項目と言えば 皆さん今いくつかわかってると思いますね
五取蘊と 五取蘊ですけど
五取蘊は何ですか？パンチュパーダなんかも
五蘊といえば五蘊ですよと
五蘊といえば色受想行識と
それは一つのマーティカなんですね
三界ですよと その場合は欲界色界無色界と三界ですよと
そういうのをマーティカ項目と言うんです
覚支といえば七つですよっていうのはマーティカなんです
道といえば八ですよと
体ですか 真理といえばつですよと
で そのようにもう項目つけて
それを徹底的に覚えておいて
それで組み合わせたり勉強したりすると
それですべてのお釈迦様の教えはマーティカにまとめているんです
それはアビダルマの仕事なんです
お経を読んでもないんです
だからアビダルマの専門家というと
同じブドウ議語はマーティカダラ
ダラっていうのは持っている
身に着いているという
アビダンミカっていうのはアビダルマのプロということで
アビダンミカをマーティカダラと言うんです
パーリ語で そこでこのすごいアビダルマのプロのお釈迦様の時代にいたんです
女性の方が あるおばあさんが
まあまあすごい豊かな幸福なね
まあおばあちゃんで もう旦那さんが亡くなっちゃって
で まあ再婚はできたんだけど
若かったんだけどね そんなことには何の興味もなく
仏教を勉強したんですね
勉強して修行して もう悟りまくって
だからマーティカ マーターと彼女に言うんですね
マーターというのは母
だからばあちゃんという言葉はあまりパーリ語でないんです
母 母ちゃんという言葉なんですね
だからマーティカ母ちゃんというふうな名前でね
マータというのはすごい褒め言葉の敬語なんです
母ということは仏教の世界ではもう大変なもう敬語なんですね
だから人を女性の人をものすごい最高に褒める
褒めたい場合は もう名前の語尾にマータという言葉を入れちゃうんですね
母という言葉を入れちゃうんですね
ですから まあどうせ母と言えばね
やっぱりすごい立場だからね
人をリーダーであって
自分が人々を管理する
もう育てる立場だから
育てる格だからね で マーティカ・マータという有名なトロのおばちゃまがいたんですね
じゃあそれでマーティカという言葉の説明なんですけど
その余計な話をやめて
さっさとテーマに入りましょう
で これでマーティカは一つはアクサラサンガホ
不善のことをまとめたところ
ニッサガサンガホ 善不善と関係なく
雑ですか で いわゆる混
ミックスしてね まあいわゆるどちらにも入る
それからボーディパッキヤサンガホ
ボーディパッキヤというのは悟りに関係あるという菩提分の節
で 悟りの働きに関係あることと
サッバサンガラ それから残ったものは全部一般的にまとめて一切節と
大したまとめ方じゃないんだけど
じゃあそこで一番目いきます
アクサラサンガホ 不善の節
で 不善ということに映えるいろんな心の働き
で 一応これ心所の働きなんです
時々心も扱います 今もう心所五十二ありますよと勉強したでしょうに
あれ あの五十二を勉強したって
もう全然役に立たないんです
あの心所の五十二がある時はある働きする
ある時はまた違う働きをする
そこら辺は勉強しなくちゃいけない
で で 一番目はアーサヴァ
漏ですね 漏は四つあるんだと
この四つの漏は有漏 見漏ですか
漏滅漏 欲漏 憂漏 嫌漏 まあなんかかっこ悪い発音ですね
だからパーリ語で覚えた方がいいんじゃないかなと
カーマーサヴァ バーサヴァ
ディッターサヴァ アヴィッジャーサヴァ
で パーリ語だったらものすごい意味が深いんですね
ただ 憂漏って言ったらなんかね
わからないんです で アーサヴァっていうのはやっぱりアースって
まあ漏れるという意味なんですね
いわゆるこの液体が流れる意味に使ってるんで
アースっていうのはこの液体がどこかへ流れていくんですね
どんな液体でも この液体の流れはもうアースというサンスクリット語の言葉で使ってるんですね
それからアーサヴァという言葉が出ているんです
で 漏れるという場合も同じことですね
液体でないと漏れませんだからね
で また漏れると言ったっても
いろいろ意味があるかもしれませんだけど
まあそれで経典では例えてるんですね
丁寧に葺いてない屋根は雨に雨が降ると漏るでしょうに
漏れるでしょうに で うちのうちを作って屋根を作ったんだけど
ちゃんと丁寧に葺いてないんですね
屋根のタイルを それで雨になっちゃったら
もう家の中にいたっても何の意味もないんです
そのように心の屋根を
サティの屋根をちゃんと葺いてないと煩悩が漏れるんだと
その漏れる煩悩が種類があるんですね
ということなんです ですから
なぜ漏というかというと
心の中に漏れるんだから
だからそういう勉強は必要なのアビダンマとしては
で 私たちの心が家に例えてみたら
でも心にはちゃんと屋根が葺いてない
サティというすごいこの徹底した屋根が葺いてない場合は
心の心という家が漏れるんですね
雨漏りをします その雨漏りは種類あるんだと
で 番目はカーマーサヴァ
カーマっていうのは欲なんですね
欲っていうのは何でしょうかね
この眼耳鼻舌身というつで刺激を受けたいという気持ちなんです
目で見たい 耳で聞きたい
鼻で香りを嗅いだい 舌で味わいたいし
体で感触を良い感触を感じたいというつの物体に対するものなんですね
体に対する働きなんですね
それは欲というんです
そういうわけで ただ人はね
心育てないで このそのまんま放っておくと
我々はあれも見たい これも見たい
あれも食べたい これも食べたい
あれを聞きたい この音楽も聞きたいという
それどんどんどんどん増えるでしょうに
やりたいことはいっぱい増えるでしょうね
すべてやりたいことが増えるのか
全部体に関する関するものなんですね
見たい見たいか 聞きたい聞きたいかとかね
どこかへ行きたいと思うことも体に関することでしょう
どこか行って何か見たい
何か食べたいと ですから心はそのまま放っておいちゃうと
知らないうちに我々はすーっとこういう感情ばっかり育てちゃうんです
心の中でどんどんどんどん溜まるんです
その感情 見たい 聞きたい
食べたい 遊びたい 味わいたい
寝たい ああだこうだとかね
そこで人間っていうのは必死になって行動しちゃうんですね
でも愚か者だからわかってないんで
単なるバカなことではないかと
動物と同じことではないか
みんな格好つけちゃうんで
私はもう毎月どこかへ旅に出たいんだと
だから毎月必ずどこかへ出かけるんだとか
威張っちゃうんで その上
愚かさの上に 私は毎年もう必ずしもこういうこと
外国旅行するんだと イタリアにも回ぐらい行ってるんだと
ああだこうだとかね 毎年行くためにアメリカで家も買っておいたんだとかね
それで威張ったりはするんだけど
その人々はこの欲 ロ カーマ
アーサヴァで心の中はずっと漏れっぱなしなんですね
そういうわけで この動物とこの次元がなかなか超えることはできない
心を放っておいちゃうとそういうことになる
2番目は まあ欲といえば
この信書の中でどっちでしたっけ？ 14の不善心所があったでしょう
その中にあの普遍的な信書 4つがあって
もう入れたかなったと
この欲の心所が 3つあります
ローバ・ディッティ・マーナ
チャートあるんだったら見てください
欲の心所が 3つあります
ローバ・ディッティ・マーナ
その中でローバという 1個の心所なんです
欲という心所 1個が時々ロとして仕事をするんです
アーサヴァとして いわゆる溜まる働きするんです
欲がどんどん溜まると
それすごい働きなんです
それから解放してる人々は一人いません
これ欲が溜まることはね
まあ修行して悟らないともう終わらないんですね
見たい 食べたい 歩きたいとかね
という欲が消えません
で それ何が悪いかと思うかもしれませんだけど
それは無知ですけどね
何が悪いんじゃなく それ悪いんです
なぜならばそれあると人が動物のまんまで
何か食べたい 何か食べたいだけで成長がまるっきりなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから ああ いい音楽聴きたいとかね
美味しい食べ物を食べたいっていうのは別に悪いわけじゃないというのは甘い話なんです
俗世間では説法でもそれは別にという風に言うんだけど
厳密に仏教を語るとそんなことじゃないんです
それはすごい悪いと もっと美味しいものを食べたいとかね
もっと楽なところに住みたいとかね
もっと環境の良いところに旅をしたいとかね
そういう何をしても欲
ロです カーマ アーサヴァなんですね
それでね すごい悪いというのは
そうするとその人間が食べる
見るということしか何もしないんです
必死になって食べ物を探す
見るものを探す 聞く音を探す
体にいい感触を探し回ったりするというと
動物と同じでしょう 犬猫と同じでしょうに
というと成長ないでしょうに
進化がないでしょうに
だからまあ可愛いと その人はね
なんかどこかへまあ遊びたいなと思ってるんだと
海に行って泳いで遊びたいなと思ってるんだから
何が悪いんですかと そんな可愛くもなんともないんです
それは進化は遅れるんです
その場合は ですから アビダンマの場合はもういわゆる修行の世界ではすごい厳しくそういうとこを言うんです
俗世間の場合は お坊さんたちもお釈迦様も一般の人々に説法するときはそんなに気にする
まあまあまあそれまあまあ普通でしょうと
人間にはまあそれなりに欲があって
家族を守って仕事をして
まあ頑張っているのは
それは素晴らしいことだと
それでも天国には行けるんだと
それしたっても天国には行けますよ
このアーサはあっても天国には行けます
ちょっと自分の心の次元だけちょっと上を向いておけば天国に行きますからね
ですから そういう天国に行くことには邪魔になるわけじゃないし
だからそんなに厳しく言ってないけど
修行の世界では 修行の立場から考えちゃうと
この欲アーサワ カーマ・アーサワあると
その人はその生命が状態がそのまんまで一方にも成長しない
進めない それは誰がやるかというと
何のことなくあの老婆という身障なんです
普段生まれるでしょう
綺麗なバラの花を見たら
綺麗な花だなと思ったら老婆が生まれてるんだけどね
何のこともないんです
その時は 同じ老婆が一時はある時はアーサとして働く
その時は危ない 同じ包丁がおいしい料理を作ってくれますけど
ある時はもう殺人鬼に
何といいますか そういうそういう狂気に変わるんだと
だからお母さんがね ちゃんとキャベツを刻んでる時は何のことなく
すごい形が美しくて 美味しいご飯食べられるぞってことなんですけど
そのままそれ握ってこうやって殺そうとしちゃうと
もう危ないんですね そういう風に老婆という身障が何のことなく
普通の毎日の日常生活の中で仕事をしていますけど
アーサになっちゃったらもう立場が変わると
2番目はババ・アーサワ
で 欲のこと言ったんだから
次に怒りのことを言うだろうと思ってもそうじゃないんです
いつでも貪瞋痴だから
まあじゃあだからカーマ・アーサワの次にまあ怒さでしょうねというね
そんなそんなもんじゃないんです
だからちゃんとマーティカを覚えなくちゃいけないんです
これはもうちゃんとした真理だから
怒りも心の中で溜まることはありますけど
アーサとして行ってないんです
ローとしては ババ・アーサワっていうのは
何でしょうかな 愚痴ですね
ババっていうのは生きていきたい気持ちなんです
これも渇愛なんです 欲なんです
生きていきたいという
生きていきたいという気持ちがあると人間何する？と言うと
ずっと輪廻転生していくんですね
こんなこと生きていきたいと思わなくても輪廻転生するんです
私は一回で死んで終わりたいなと思ったっても
それできません 輪廻転生の心の流れだからね
それはもう流れちゃうんです
ですから 余計な欲なんです
あれも この愚痴というのは
ババ・アーサワっていうのはなくてもいいんです
で とにかくババ・アーサワっていうのは
やっぱり生きていきたい
永遠になりたいと 死にたくはないと思う気持ちなんですね
死にたくはない 永遠になりたいと思ったら
その人は輪廻を輪廻に執着しているんです
解脱しようとしないんです
それで生きていきたい人がいろんなことをするんです
仕事もするし 悪いこともするし
経済活動もするし いろんなことをやってるんですね
朝から晩まで それでよくよく考えると動物と同じなんですね
進化は 生きていきたいのは動物も同じことだから
生きていきたいんだから
動物は朝から晩まで餌探して
それで繁殖時期でも子供を作って
それから死んじゃうんですね
それぐらいのこと動物もやってる
それ生きていきたいんだからなんです
人間にも生きていきたいという欲が
このローとしてアーサとして現れちゃったら
自分の人生はただ生きることに終わってしまっちゃうんです
何の成長もなくなっちゃう
ですから アーサは生まれたら進化はストップしちゃうんですね
解脱は不可能になるんです
そこで この怒ろうと言ってもババアースワと言っても
信書の中で何かというと
それまた老婆という欲という信書
同じ信書なんです  3番目
見怒ディッターセル ディッタっていうのは邪見ですね
極論なんですね で それなんで老にアーサーにしたんですかね
ディッティがいろんな邪見
我々の心の中でずっと漏れてくるんですかね
心にいろんな意見漏れるんですかね
漏れるんです まあ知識もない代わりに
もうなんかくだらないね
いろいろ哲学を読んだり
いろんな情報を頭に入れたり
いろんな余計なことを考えたりするとどうなるんですかね
心の中で 世の中はこういうことだ
あの人はこういうこと意見ばっかりでしょ
その場合は 今の政治はこういうこういうことだ
もうそういう風にいろんなものについて見解がずっと生まれっぱなしで
そこで見解が生まれっぱなしだから
見解というのは全部実体論だからね
無常論じゃないんだから
その人はそれで満足して誤解してもう堕落してしまっちゃうんです
一切の見解を捨てることは 1番目の悟りなんです
そこで心は放っておいちゃうとどうなるかというと
ずっと見解生まれっぱなしで
我々勉強するんだとか何とかして見解作るだけなんですね
ですから 何か聞いたらすぐ何か意見が漏れちゃう
何か食べたら あ あの店のあの食べ物はすごい美味しいんですよと
もう見解が生まれている
ですから 人間にはもう日常茶飯事でありとあらゆる見解がずっと漏れっぱなしなんです
それも悟りには邪魔と
すごい気をつけろと 見解っていうのは心象の中で何かというと
ディッティという 欲のセット 3つありますね
そこで 2番目ディッティという見という心象なんですね
それはローとしても働くんです
4番目は無明ロアウィッジャーセル
アウィッジャーっていうのは
この全てのものは無常であるということを体験できない状態
だから無常ということは
ものが現れて消える 消えて違うものが現れる
それは消えてまた違うものが現れるという流れが体験することは無常なんです
でも我々の 認識ではそれ不可能なんです
物が現れたら見える 消えると見えません
また現れたら見える そこで前に現れたものも今現れたものも一個ですけど
似ているんだから同じものだと誤解する
それで我々にはどうしようもなく無常はわからなくなっちゃうんです
現象が瞬間瞬間消えるんだけど
消えるたびに現れる現象が前の現象と似ているんです
だから同じものだと誤解する
ですから 人間には無常っていうのは体験できない
普通常識で修行以外はそれに無明というんです
アヴィッチャーというんです
だから人が音楽を聴くたびに無明が漏れるんです
音楽自体は無常なんですけど
ああ綺麗な曲だと また一回聴こうと思っちゃうでしょうに
また一回何を聴くんですかね？その人が同じ曲を聴くとすごい錯覚しているんです
だから音楽を聴いちゃったら
あ 綺麗な曲だ もう一回聴こう
同じこともう一回聞こえませんよ
でも我々はそう思っているんです
ああ この間あの店で蕎麦を食べた
美味しかった また行こうと
バカバカらしいね また行ったって同じ蕎麦は食えないし
ですから 我々の日常生活の中で食べたり見たり聞いたりするとどうなるかというと
無明がどんどん増えるんですね
どんどんアヴィッチャーというものが漏れてしまうんです
そこで強力に我々は輪廻に
存在に 苦しみに定着してしまう
どうしようもない羽目なんです
で なんで写真撮るんですかね？あ
これは綺麗なところだとかね
あ 記念に写真撮ろうとかね
僕個人にとってはあれほど無意味なこと
僕はもうカメラはもう結構いいの買いましたけどね
写真撮る 買いましたけど
フィルム枚入れたら 二十四枚のフィルム一枚入れて
これ終わるためには二年かかったんです
とにかく いつでも何かあったら写真撮りますよと思って行くんだけど
もう忘れるか まあいいやと
そこで何か必要な誰かの何か写真ですか
必要な時もありますからね
誰か人の写真とかなんとかとかね
撮って じゃあそれを現像して
そういう仕事に使おうかなと思ったら思って現像に出したところで
これはあまりにも古いすぎて現像できませんという返事が返ってきたんです
ですからまあ で 普通だったらね
例えば何か見て写真撮ったりするっていうことはどういうことかね
誰か見て あ これは本当にあるものだ
また再現しようという気持ちでしょうね
再現できないんです その気持ちはあるんですね
それは無明 ですから 人間にとってはいつでもこの無明は無明だけで終わらないんです
無明は漏として漏れて漏れて漏れてどんどん強化するんですね
強化していない場合はいいんだけど
で 例えばずっと瞑想している人々は
例えば二十年瞑想しているんだと
二十年瞑想しているんだから悟ってないんだと
二十年やったってもというと
その人にはこの強化していない
ただ無明は無明であるだけ
結構いるんです 全て無常ということは理解しているし
納得もしているし 輪廻は良くないと納得もしているし
解脱したいなという決意もあるし
でも悟れない それでも
その場合はこの漏はないんだけどね
毎日余計なことしませんだからね
修行ばっかりしているんだからね
ただ心にある無明が切れないだけ
心にこの見えないんだから
無常がね これはね カラクリできない
これこのパチンコと同じく
パチンコで大当たり出すことと同じく
努力すれば誰でも出せますけど
なかなか出せないんだと
ようなもので悟れない場合はありますけどね
普通の人々の場合は この無明っていうのは
この静かにこの猫の子猫のように寝ているものじゃないんです
どんどんこの子猫が成長して成長して成長して
巨大な大虎にぐらいに大きくなっちゃうんです
猫も虎ぐらいに大きくなったら人を食うんです
で そういうわけでアーサヴァが四つある
この四つは心所で数えればローバとディッティと